I want to talk about an angle to the
recent presidential debate that we've
not yet discussed we did a lot of
discussion about Donald Trump's lies we
did quite a bit of discussion about the
issues that were covered and where areas
in which Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump did well or didn't do well but we
haven't talked so much about what wasn't
talked about in that first presidential
debate and there's a really interesting
article that I would take a look at if I
were you uh by Adam Johnson of fairness
and accuracy in reporting and it goes
into what topics were not covered in the
first presidential debate and very often
looking at the absence of something
tells us just as much or more at looking
at the presence of something for example
when we looked at corporate media
coverage of Occupy Wall Street on the
one hand we could look at well Fox News
was much more aggressively negative
about the protesters as people versus
CNN that was much more positive about
the protesters at people as people
etcetera but what was missing from all
corporate media in the coverage of
Occupy Wall Street was hey let's discuss
areas in which capitalism has served us
well and areas in which capitalism has
not served as well which was really one
of the main points of Occupy Wall Street
that was missing from corporate media
coverage about Occupy Wall Street so
let's apply that now in looking at Adam
Johnson's article about what was missing
from the presidential debate the article
makes some good points but I don't agree
with everything that's being said some
of the topics that Adam Johnson points
to as being missing I think there's a
pretty good case to be made that they
should not really be debate topics and
I'm gonna get into that okay so how did
the topics play out we were told the
first debate was about it achieving
prosperity America's direction and
securing America it played out as
basically an opportunity for a lot of
discussion of everything from emails
insults tax returns etcetera not invalid
topics but really not particularly
substantive policy discussion so Adam
Johnson points out listen in this debate
we had no questions
about poverty we had no questions or
discussion about abortion not really
anything about climate change
immigration which has been a huge part
of trumps uh fear mongering campaign was
essentially missing healthcare student
debt privacy LGBT rights drug policy
missing from the debate so here's what I
want to suggest to you uh our audience
some of these issues are very notable
because their issues of importance and
they are very very valuable issues to
discuss for example immigration huge
issue it's being used to push people for
and/or against candidate Donald Trump is
made it a central element of his
campaign not discussed poverty huge huge
issue poverty is an issue of paramount
importance not discussed within that
first debate but some of these other
issues I'm less convinced really have a
place in national political debates I'm
gonna give you an example right let's
talk about abortion abortion is a legal
medical procedure I would say that it is
a victory it says a lot about our
country if abortion is not part of
national presidential campaigns because
really particularly now that more than
half of Americans for the first time
since roe v wade say that abortion
should be legal in most cases there
really shouldn't be anything
controversial about abortion now I know
you'll hear me say this and you'll say
well David you may be right that there
shouldn't be anything controversial but
there is still huge opposition to
abortion particularly among the
Republican right the evangelical
religious right a lot of money is being
raised around being against abortion so
it is controversial and you're right and
I completely agree with you but the
absence of abortion in a national debate
i believe is by and large a good thing
let me give you another example LGBT
rights LGBT rights really should not be
controversial do you want to get married
to someone you should be able to get
married to that person regardless of
what genitals you were they were born
with that's uh absolutely clear to me if
you work at a job you should not be able
to be fired the
cuz of your perceived or actual sexual
orientation there should be no
discrimination allowed based on gender
we shouldn't be dealing with laws about
which bathroom can you use and how can
you prove which bathroom you can use so
i think it is progress if LGBT rights no
longer have to be parts of these
presidential debates however and you're
absolutely right if you're about to tell
me but David there is discrimination you
still can be fired in many states for
your perceived or actual sexual
orientation so it should be part of the
debate I agree with you I agree with you
but my big picture reaction is poverty
being missing from a presidential debate
and LGBT rights discussions being
missing from a presidential debate they
are different because one is an issue
that is objectively an issue that needs
to be fixed and dealt with whereas the
other is something that is only an issue
because of retrograde conservatives one
thing they definitely should have talked
about is corruption in politics yeah I
mean to this day we don't know Donald
Trump's position on citizens united yeah
but will the the reason we're not going
to see too much discussion in national
debates about what you're really getting
at is campaign finance is because no
matter what ninety-nine point nine
percent of national politicians say
about what we've got a we've got to
prevent this anonymous spending that you
can do they'll come up with some line by
and large these major politicians are in
power because of the system we have and
there's a huge disincentive for them to
want to change it so there's what I call
sometimes Pat no-win topics where to
whose advantage is it to talk about it
maybe Trump is actually better off on
this one cuz he can say hey I'm not
someone who has ever benefited as a
recipient of the money that floats
around although he said he has been
involved in buying politicians with
donations but there's really no upside i
think to either of them to bring that up
and not only to the candidates to but
the commission on presidential debates
run by the two parties yeah and by the
network's yet know that it's just it's a
lose-lose and another example i gave was
uh we hear Trump and Hillary Clinton
both talk about I'll bring jobs back
we're not gonna stop keep sending jobs
to Mexico we're gonna get us out our
selves out of trade agreements whatever
their
policies are neither of them says hey
you know what we are going to lose
millions of jobs in the next 15 years
because of automation because it's it's
0 so you gain absolutely nothing if
you're trump or Clinton by admitting no
matter what she says no matter what he
says no matter what I say there are
going to be jobs lost it's a loser it's
not going to get you any votes
whatsoever so but not all absent topics
created equally is my reaction to Adam
Johnson's article about what wasn't
discussed at the debate let me know what
you think about this i'm on twitter at d
pakman and of course we are all on
facebook at facebook.com slash david
pakman show i've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars suvs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
zipcar dot-com slash david